Parents.
Hello, parents.
The holidays are upon us.
And it's time for some good cheer.
And some straight talk.
So let's dispense with the pleasantries...
...and have at it.
First, don't overtape the presents.
It's no fun for the person to rip up.
Believe me, I've been there.
Secondly,...
...it's been said, "Buy a kid a gift and they'll play with the box."
Well, that's a myth.
And frankly, it's a little insulting.
Maybe kids played with boxes in the old days.
Back then, all they had to play with was a stick.
Or a rock.
Then maybe a box felt like a step up.
Not today!
No, no, no.
Today I'll take a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle, thank you.
Thirdly,...
...it's better to give than to receive.
You hear that a lot this time of year.
Well, you know what?
We're kids.
Receiving is what we do.
We'd receive all day if we could.
What leads me to point four...
...it's three.
Point four:...
...regarding Christmas lists.
We will be changing our minds until the morning of.
So I might suggest that you overshop.
An extra Barbie here,...
...a razor scooter there,...
...never hurt anyone.
It's called damage control.
'Cause no one wants a Christmas morning meltdown.
Least of all us.
And finally, at the end of the gift receiving,....
...we will say,...
"That's all?"
"That's it?"
"There's gotta be more, right?"
"Isn't there any more gifts?"
"No?"
Sorry, but we will say that.
We're kids.
That's what kids say.
It's not because we don't love what you got us.
It's because we love it so much,...
...we want more.
Kmart.
Get in.
Get more Christmas.